[Music]
Hello and greetings to you all. You're
watching I'd like to know, our Bible
question and answer program here at
SumTV and Secrets Unsealed. My name is
CA Murray and with me is Pastor Steven
Boore, our president and founder and
Pastor David Salazar who superintends
our Latino channel here at SUMTV. Thank
you for sharing what is probably a very
busy day for you, giving us just a
little bit of your time and we pray that
uh you will be blessed from your sitting
here today. Pastor Bo, again I would ask
you would you please open us up in in
prayer?
Certainly. Father in heaven, we come
before you before your awesome
throne knowing that uh your wisdom is
infinite
but ours knowledge is very finite.
Therefore, we plead for the presence of
your spirit as we begin this
program. Help us to answer the questions
in harmony with your word, in harmony
with the spirit of prophecy. And I ask
that this program will be a blessing to
those who are watching it. Please be
with us. We pray in the precious and
holy name of Jesus. Amen. Amen. And
amen. One little bit of housekeeping we
want to take care of. Should you want to
be part of this program, if you have a
Bible-based question that you would like
to ask, then you can contact us at TV at
sums as in
marytv.org and we will get to your
questions. We promise you just as soon
as we possibly can. Pastor Boore, uh,
you just came back from a fairly lengthy
trip to South America. So, we're going
to put you to work because there's no
rest for the weary. So, this is a rather
long question. So, I'm going to ask you
to just read it for us and then we'll
kind of work our way through the answer.
Okay. Well, this question comes to us
from Karen. Uh, originally she says that
she's from Malaysia, but now she lives
in Western Australia. Thank you very
much for writing to us. Uh I don't know
that I can really synthesize this
without going through it. So, so bear
with me. I have this question that I
can't fully understand and hoping that
you may give me your advice. I had
recently read the book Early Writings.
In the chapter about the third angel's
message, Mrs. White wrote about William
Miller. On page 257, she wrote, and now
she quotes, "My attention was then
called to William Miller, I saw leading
men watching him, and fearing lest he
should receive the third angel's message
and the commandments of God." At length,
William Miller raised his voice against
the light from heaven. He leaned to
human wisdom instead of divine. But
being broken with ardorous labor in his
master's cause and by age, he was not as
accountable as those who kept him from
the truth. They are responsible. The sin
rests upon them. And she wrote, she
continues, quoting, "God suffered him to
fall under the power of Satan, the
dominion of death, and hid him in the
grave from those who were constantly
drawing him from the truth." I saw that
William Miller aired as he was soon to
enter the heavenly
Canaan. And then she
continues, "Others led him to this.
Others must account for it. But angels
watch the precious dust of this servant
of God, and he will come forth at the
sound of the last trumpet. Now comes the
questions based on these
quotations. My questions. William Miller
obviously was given the third angel's
message, but he leaned to human wisdom
instead of divine, as Mrs. White pointed
out. Why is he not accountable for his
own decisions?
Why is it that others led him to uh led
him to this? Others must account for it.
Why will he be resurrected at Jesus
second coming? Isn't that um actually
doesn't that sound like he's saved by
his works? Please don't get me wrong.
I'm not against William Miller being
saved, but just can't understand why he
is not judged by the decision he made.
That is to listen to men instead of the
divine. Do I miss something here that I
don't see? Looking forward to your views
on this. So, it's a rather long uh
commentary and then uh short questions.
Uh but there's no way we can answer the
questions without the background that
she's giving. So, how do we deal with
this um these quotations of Ellen White
that William Miller rejected the third
angel's message but is still going to be
saved?
Well, I I think that we are uh we're
looking it through an perspective of
rejecting the light
that you are
given and you purposely say I don't want
to hear that. I don't want to accept the
truth. I don't want to accept that
light. And in the case of William
Miller, it's it's a little different
because he was already of a of an age.
She actually mentions that spirit
prophecy. This is why it says that he
was already of age and that because of
his age, the Lord was no longer
considering
his rejection of the light as necessary
to validate his life as a just man. I
think that the example in the Bible,
there's a couple of examples that come
to my mind of something similar to this
experience. And for example, the we have
uh the example of Noah. The first
example that comes to my mind as you
know Noah was a man who um the Lord
directed gave him a message he built an
ark and he saved his family. However,
post the you know the flood
Noah got drunk. He made a mistake. I
mean, you know, and is not necessarily
something that he should have done, but
it's there in the Bible to show that he
made a mistake post the flood and that
because of that mistake, something that
was unlawful happened to him with his
son. Um, had Noah not been drunk, for
example, he could have avoided such an
incident. So, and then another example
that comes to my mind is the case of
Lot. Lot, you know, he was a the Bible
speaks of him of as a just man. And yet
because he went to Sodom and after
Sodom, he got involved in a experience
where his own daughters make him drunk
and he, you know, they they committing
sex with him. So there was a huge
difficulty in his apparent rejection of
following God's, you know, guidance.
Nevertheless, the Lord and the Bible
speaks of him as a just man. And
therefore I think that when we look at
cases like William Miller where you see
certain um in this case the evidence
that he rejected the light based on the
influence of others. God is not taking
his him to be accountable according to
the sister white because he had already
fulfilled a purpose in leading preparing
people to understand the coming of the
Lord and because of his work. These
decisions that he was made later in his
life are not counted against him mainly
as he already has defined his character
and his decision for the Lord. I think
that it would have been too much maybe
and God knew the conditions and the
situations. That's why the Lord said to
him, well, you know, just like in the
case of Noah, in the case of Lot, I'm
not going to judge you for a mistake you
have done at the end of your life. I
will look at at everything you have done
and and because you live according to
what you have received, I think you are
are in good, you know, uh he's he's
justified for that experience. So, I
would say that we have to let the Lord
make the final decision. He's a judge
and he knows that, you know, how to do a
judgment that's right, not like ours.
I'd like to add a couple names to your
your your pantheon of of righteous men
who have skid marks on their on their
record. Um, Abraham, who had a couple
times when he lied to protect himself.
David, who committed an act that he
never really got out from the under the
consequences of, but Acts tells us David
is a saved man. So is Abraham. Um
because you are God's person does not
mean you are not free from certain human
frailties. She talks about William
Miller being a broken man. Ella White
does cosign that. He was preaching an
average of 720 sermons a year. You know
he he was burning himself out for for
the Lord. When you when you're keeping
up that kind of pace as you get a little
bit older and he started late in life.
He was no child when he began uh
searching the Bible 1832. Um he he he he
looked and he searched and he looked and
he searched and he preached and he
preached and he preached. And sometimes
when you're wearing yourself out for the
Lord, you are susceptible to the the
intrigues of those around you. You know,
he he didn't really accept the October
22 date till about several weeks before.
You know, he he held on to about
October. He didn't he didn't but they
kind of pushed him and they pushed him
and massaged him and massaged him and
finally he took he took the date. So
this is what happens to to men who give
themselves up for the Lord and and and
the Lord realizes that James White five
strokes. Mhm. Five strokes, you know,
and each one Ellen White says changed
his personality just a little bit. Uh
somewhere between strokes four and five,
he actually ordered her to come back
from California. Uh she was doing some
work. He was back in Michigan. He
ordered to come back and she said, "No,
I'll come back when I finish the work
that the Lord has." And then she wrote
Sarah McInver and said, you know, he
changes so much with these with these
strokes. I don't even know for sure what
person I'm coming back to when I get
back there, you know, but I I know I
love him. I know he loves the Lord, but
these these strokes are altering his
personality just a little bit. So
because you work for the Lord, it does
not free you from those infirmities that
attend coming to the Lord. Which is why
I want to add we need to pray for our
pastor. Yes. Because they are under
special attack. you're under special
attack. You had a ministry, a ministry
that is doing great work for the Lord.
You don't think the devil is upset with
Steven Boore? You know, you're on his
radar. He he knows who you are. Uh so,
so when when we pray, you need to pray
for your pastors because
those natural things that come from
burning yourself out, working so hard
for the Lord, you don't get a pass on
that. So, is he responsible? Yeah. But
is he responsible enough to lose his
salvation? No. Uh he he did pay for it.
He he burnt himself out. He died at an
early age. Uh uh but those are the
things that you sacrifice when you sign
up to be a soldier for the Lord. Uh of
course the the retirement policy is
great. You know, he's he's in heaven.
Angels angels mark that that grave. But
by the same token, you don't get a a
pass on on an easy life when you sign up
for for the Lord.
I'm glad that God is the judge. Yeah.
and we're
not uh God takes into account our state
of mind.
I think that uh she answers her own
question
uh particularly in the part where it
says he
learned he leaned to human wisdom
instead of divine. And then she explains
why. Uh, but being broken, there you go.
With arduous
labor in his master's cause and by
age, he was not as accountable as those
who kept him from the truth. We need to
remember that God takes into account
even where we're born. Amen. He takes
into account our u state of mind. He
takes into account our physical
abilities. That's why I'm glad he's the
judge. Amen. Because if we were the
judges, you know, we we would judge on
the basis of what can be seen. God
judges on the basis of what cannot be
seen. Uh you know, when you look at
William Miller, they tried to kill him
several times. They weren't successful.
He was attacked. Mhm. Uh you know, he
went through three disappointments.
Yeah. He said that Jesus was going to
come back around the year 1843.
Then he said in the spring of
1844 and then last uh as CA mentioned
you know he believed um that Jesus was
going to come back on October 22 1844.
Three disappointments devastating
disappointments. Yes. This man loved the
Lord. Yeah. He wanted to see Jesus come.
Right. Not only him but everybody who
worked with him. They burned themselves
out. Not only that, they spent all of
their resources because they love Jesus
and they wanted to see Jesus come. So we
should not be too harsh on William
Miller. We can be more harsh on those
that kept him from the truth. Amen. You
know, William Miller got to the point
where he said, you know, let's not let's
not pursue this. You know, I've been
wrong three times. uh and so he could
not really fully grasp the third angel's
message, the importance of the third
angel's message. He was burned out. He
had gone through several
disappointments. Uh and God took takes
into account those factors. Amen. And
so, um we will see William Miller in the
kingdom. Yeah. Angels are guarding his
tomb. Amen. And I praise the Lord that
we'll have the opportunity of seeing
seeing him there. And he started as an
old man. I mean, he started burning
himself out when he was older. He was no
baby when he So, I hope that this helps
in answering the question, uh, let's not
be too hard on him. We can be harder on
the people who who actually, uh,
surrounded him and kept him from the
truth. Um, you know, you think for
example of Martin Luther. Martin Luther
didn't believe in the Sabbath, right? In
fact, in some venues, he actually, you
know, said that Sunday is the day we're
supposed to keep. Um does that mean that
Luther can't be saved? No. He w his
mission at that time was to um fight
against legalism.
Exactly. And say we're the right you
know individuals are justified by grace
through faith not by their works. Amen.
And he fulfilled the mission for which
God sent him. And William Miller did
also. So I think that that that helps us
understand a little bit more u how God
judged Miller. And by the way during the
millennium we'll be able to review this
and when we review it we'll say oh thank
you Lord you did it the right way. I
think the important point as well is to
know that we are not to
use, you know, people like like William
Miller who because of his age, because
of his experience, his own
disappointments, he rejected a a lie
that was coming and used that as an
excuse for us to say, well, you know, if
he did it, I can reject it and be okay
and be safe. It's a different story. you
know, we are not to use the the limits
of a human individual to make a rule for
ourselves to say, you know, it's okay.
We reject certain lights now because he
did it and he's saved. And that's the
danger that we have to, you know, be
afraid of of committing today to try to
excuse our own neglect of the truth or
our own rejection of the light because
thinking that God's going to save me
regardless, you know, because I have
received some of the light. And and I
think that is very important to know
that the the church that established
among all the other churches in these
last days is the Adventist church who
has everything that has given to us for
our benefit, for our life, for our
salvation. And when we reject what has
been revealed to us now, we are not in
the same position as he was, we are
openly saying to the Lord, I don't want
your light. And that is going against
the Holy Spirit. So I I think that we
need to just uh not use as an excuse.
God will judge as you said pastor. Well,
you know, we he's going to judge
according to the infinite knowledge that
he has and uh we are to be careful not
to use cases like them to to try to
justify our own inability to follow the
truth that he has given to us. Amen. You
know, we we talk about this and I know
we're we're getting to wrap up here. You
you look at Moses. You know, making some
of these mistakes may affect your
quality of life here on earth. But great
is your reward in heaven. So Moses told
was told you can't go into the promised
land. Where has he has he spent the last
3,000 plus years? In heaven. So don't
cry for Moses. You know, he's better
than we are. He's he's already there.
So, you know, you get the what looks bad
in in the overall scheme of things. You
know, Genesis 18 says, "Will not the
judge of all the earth do right. We know
that God will do right." When you open
this book, you open it with the
understanding that the author of this
book is going to do right. who's trying
to get you in, not keep you out. Joseph
Bates and then I'm done. Um, Ellen White
had to tell him, "God has told me to
tell you, you need to retire. You know,
you need to quit because of the life he
had lived. He he was the kind of person,
well, oh, smoking's bad, just stop it.
You know, no 12-day planet. Just quit.
Uh, drinking is bad, stop drinking, you
know. Uh, this is bad. Just stop it." He
was a very aesthetic kind of person. He
just if he saw it and you could prove it
to him, he just he just did it. He lived
fasting a lot and burning himself out.
same thing uh burning as Eli said, you
know, it's time to time to just stop
because you've done what God has asked
you to do. Uh and now you can take you
can take a little rest. Well, these
pioneers were like that. They gave
themselves to the Lord and um uh
although it looked like they lived a
hard life, they had the endgame in mind.
They were looking at heaven. Heaven was
in their view. So we we praise the Lord
for that. William Miller never gave up
his hope in the second coming of Christ.
He was disappointed. Yeah.
discouraged, but he never lost focus
that Jesus is going to come and that we
need to be ready for his coming and that
we need to love his coming. So, he never
lost the goal from his mind. Yeah. But
he would just he just was not able to
grasp further truth. Yes. Because of all
the experiences that he had been
through. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. All right.
Well done. Thank you so much. Uh, our
time is getting away from us, so I think
we have time to slip
to Tanzania. Yes. Um, Pastor Salazar,
would you read this for us, please?
Absolutely. This question comes from
Matias from Tanzania and it
says, "Greetings from Tanzania. I hope
this email finds you well. I have a
question regarding marriage and biblical
principles that I would like your
guidance on. Is it biblically wrong for
a man to marry a woman older than him?
Some people argue that because Adam was
created first and was therefore older
than Eve, it is against God's design for
a man to marry a woman older than
himself, even if it's by a day. They
say, "How can a man whose wife is older
than him claim that his wife is his rib
when the woman existed before the man?"
They also claim that Adam's authority
over Eve is steam from him being created
first. Does this mean that if a man
marries another woman, the wife becomes
the head of the husband and the husband
is obligated to submit to her authority?
I will appreciate your insight on this
matter to better understand what the
Bible and spiritual prophecy say about
it. Thank you for your time and
assistance. Blessings uh Matitheas. So
very clear question and uh what can we
say about that? Well, basically uh the
issue is not age, the issue is
gender. So, so the answer is very
simple. Uh you know the the issue of
headship has nothing to do with your
age. Amen. It has to do with your
gender. Uh let's go to 1 Timothy chapter
2 and verses 9 and 10 where the apostle
Paul draws on this argument of being
created first and and the woman sinning
sinning first.
Um, let's see. Where did I say we were
going? First Timothy 2. 1 Timothy
chapter
2. Is it first Timothy chapter? Yeah,
chapter 2 and verse uh 11 and
12. It says, "And I do not permit a
woman to teach, verse 12, or to have
authority over a man, but to be in
silence. For Adam was formed first, then
Eve, and Adam was not deceived, but the
woman being deceived fell into
transgression. Uh so, so you notice here
that the issue has to do not with age.
The issue has to do with gender. Yeah.
Uh this is further corroborated by what
we find in 1 Corinthians chapter 11. And
um here the Apostle Paul puts the nail
in the coffin so to speak. 1 Corinthians
chap uh 11 uh in verses 1 to3 it says
um let's see here verse let's just read
verse three. But I want you to know that
the head of every man is
Christ. Mh. The head of the
woman is man
and the head of Christ is God. Mhm. So,
so once again, uh, in the days of Paul,
that was still the order. Yeah. That God
is the head of Christ, Christ is the
head of the man, and the man is the head
of the woman. Once again, it has to do
not with age, it has to do with gender.
Mhm. Right. Right. And so, uh, it
doesn't really matter if you marry a
woman who's slightly older or even more
much older. Mhm. Because it's not an
issue of the age of when you were born.
The issue is gender. Absolutely. the you
know the the I think that some of these
arguments that he has been receiving
from individuals are are really
not accurate in the in in in the in the
intention of what they're trying to say.
uh a woman who is
older is certainly not the one that is
that doesn't make her the like you
mentioned pastor the head of the
household is is the is the gender that
makes the head of the household and in
the situation uh there of of of I've
actually looked through spirit prophets
in regards to to the council against
marrying uh against older you know
husband or a wife she only really talks
about that when there's a big age
difference And in regards to the
difficulty that it will be for raising
children if the age is such a difference
for both sides, she considers that it's
is something that has to be take in
consideration. But there's never a said,
you know, from the spirit prophecy that
says a man or a woman or a man should
not marry older woman. Such a thing is
not does not exist. So I can confidently
say that in 1 Timothy chapter 3, the
apostle Paul uh actually gives the
characteristics of a bishop or an over
that really means overseer. Essopus
um it says a bishop then must be
blameless the husband of one wife. It
doesn't say here that husband has to be
older than the wife. Right. Once again
it has to do with gender. In the book of
Titus it says the same thing. Yeah.
husband of one wife. Amen. So, it's not
a matter of age, it's a matter of
gender. Amen. Amen. We hope that you've
had a good time listening. We've had a
good time presenting. God bless you and
keep you until we see you again.
Bye-bye.
[Music]